winter is coming we got some stellar
highs and some abysmal lows because of
it
the climb episode six of the third
season momentum still being maintained
at this point my fears of it going back
to the pacing of the first two episodes
pretty much completely gone with almost
every episode we're getting different
characters getting the spotlight and in
other shows that might be annoying it
would be like well where's the central
person but in this one all these
characters well almost all of them are
so strong that it's worth them just
having a little bit of spotlight and
then fading back for bid lord baelish in
this episode is a really great example
because he's always been a bit of a
sneaky guy but we really get the
true extent of his ambition and the
depths of which he's prepared to sink in
order to try and achieve it to see him
squaring off against varus and you know
varys just whenever he's in a scene with
somebody he brings out the best in other
characters in addition to being a great
character on his own diana rigg as elena
tyrell yeah i actually remembered the
character's name this time instead of
just going ah you know diana rigg
square's off against tywin what a great
pairing i'm just loving seeing her just
spar in these sort of negotiations
getting information out of people's
she's another one just bringing the out
the best in other characters and of
course it just reinforces with tywin he
really is the only guy who is has
anything even close to a degree of
control it's not an iron grip by any
means but pretty much everybody else
they know what they want
he knows how to actually get it we get
some more stuff with the brotherhood
what i called last time pretty much
happened that the woman in red showed up
and immediately links up with the
brotherhood because they're all
worshiping the lord of life it played
out better than i thought it was going
to because even though they're all
worshiping the same god there's still
some tension and then maintaining that
keeps it interesting it could have
gotten very dull very quick if everyone
was like and now we fight together
thankfully not the case it's just not
that kind of show i don't know why i was
even worried about that oh god poor
theon greyjoy just still being tortured
and i really feel bad for this guy at
this point i mean he's not a good guy
necessarily but he doesn't deserve what
he's getting and that's always a tricky
thing when you're dealing with torture
because eventually it's no longer plot
it's just watching a guy get tortured
and they're being really good about
introducing enough new information in
any of these given scenes that it still
feels like it's necessary in addition to
just sort of touching base and
establishing yeah he's still here so
there's a lot of good strong material in
this episode there's also a couple of
things that really are driving me nuts
sansa again she hasn't grown she hasn't
learned she's still getting obsessed
with pretty dresses and looking forward
to a wedding and wake up i understand
why the character's still there she has
plot value but right now she's just a
plot point she's not a character anymore
so i'd rather they just sort of don't
show her anymore just talk about her
move her around like she's a commodity
because that's effectively all she's
good for right now until there's a
massive shift in her character i don't
want to see her anymore but you know as
much as sansa annoyed me she's not even
what drove me most crazy about this
episode you remember that romantic
pairing i talked about before well not
only is it still going on it's now
massively front and center and it's
being treated in a way that romantic
pairings have never been treated on this
show before there's been romance up to
this point but it's always been sort of
presented very matter-of-factly and it's
usually been somewhat unconventional
it's just sort of there and you're
watching it grow but now it's very clear
that it's like you who must care about
these characters and we are going to
raise the stakes for them and you will
care and well you know what i don't
because it's so generic and it's such a
it's like a teen romance pairing and for
me it completely took the wind out of
what is supposed to be the centerpiece
of this entire episode and
the fact that the episode ends on
swelling music and these two embracing
and a kiss i just wanted to puke
so this episode when it was good it was
great when it was bad
still looking forward to the next one
just secretly hoping that one of these
two in this pairing gets killed because
as long as they're together i don't find
them interesting and the way it's being
building they're always gonna be
together i can't really think of a
question to go along with this episode
so you know what if you've seen it
whatever your general thoughts are on
the episode put them down in the
comments let's talk about them and until
next time this council is adjourned